a new investigation claims the United
States is the most dangerous place to
give birth in the developed world every
year in the u.s. more than 50,000
mothers are severely injured during or
after childbirth 700 women die maternal
death in the United States has been
steadily rising and the US now has the
highest rate in the developed world in a
story you'll see first on CBS this
morning USA Today conducted a four year
investigation into the nation's
maternity hospitals the paper spoke to
several families who lost loved ones and
women who were permanently harmed during
their deliveries in one example a Lee
Lowery had internal bleeding after
having a baby by c-section
it took medical staff hours to act on
the warning signs and in that time she
nearly bled to death one minute I could
hear people talking the next minute I
couldn't hear anything one minute I
could see people the next minute it was
just black I was really scared because I
knew that that that I shouldn't have
been feeling that way they wheeled her
out I said that's that's my life right
there they take care of her boy Holly
needed a hysterectomy to stop the
bleeding she and her husband Shawn then
sued Knox Community Hospital in Ohio
they settled out of court the doctor and
hospital denied wrongdoing and Knox
community told us it could not comment
on the case due to patient privacy laws
USA TODAY's Allison Young is here with
us with more on the papers investigation
good morning to Allison Warren I read
your article and man I couldn't believe
what I was reading to be here in this
country but let's start with Ali's story
because this is not an isolated incident
but tell everybody what Ali does for a
living so Ali is a labor and delivery
nurse I mean and it happened in her
hospital it did and you said people
should really be outraged by what's
happening in this country a lot of women
are dying that don't need to die why
absolutely the experts say that about
50% of the deaths of women from
childbirth related causes could be
prevented if they were given better
medical care and that's a really
surprising thing given that we are one
of the wealthiest countries in the world
and we spend so much on medical care and
we're not just talking about the women
who died we're talking about fifty
thousand US women who are suffering
life-altering harms they're having to
hysterectomies they can't have babies
anymore they end up in the ICU when they
should be bonding with their babies and
a significant percentage of those don't
need to happen or the harms could be
reduced with better better medical care
Alison I thought it was so interesting
you think about the pain and how
dangerous childbirth is but what you
found is that actually many of the
dangers happen after the baby is born so
what is happening in the lack of care
that mothers are receiving so there are
two leading causes of childbirth deaths
and injuries one of them is hemorrhage
and the other is severe hypertension
blood pressure disorders and both of
those require hospital officials to pay
attention to the early warning signs and
get people treatments quickly but what
we found is that that's often not
happening but bleeding is very common in
childbirth yeah absolutely and one of
the things that happens is there's
normal bleeding but at a certain point
it crosses the line into a dangerous
hemorrhage and part of the issues
experts say is that many hospitals the
the doctors and the nurses they eyeball
the amount of blood they take an
educated guess but what they should be
doing they're saying is they should be
actually measuring the blood loss and by
doing that by weighing blood-soaked
items by using calibrated containers
they can catch it early and get
life-saving treatments faster before
things spiral out of control
Allison it's the problem that there
aren't enough staff is it that they're
just missing this and that it's a simple
fix what's the solution experts say it's
an issue of training these things have
been known for many years as things that
need to be done but it needs to be made
a priority they say at hospitals because
what I've what I understand is sometimes
that it becomes such a routine thing
that everybody's moving on and and that
that is just a part of the system and
that if you have a more deliberate
process which is just making it a little
bit slower but when you make it slower
you can't do as much and there's a cost
issue one of the things that is being
advocated by groups like the aim program
is having checklists that literally you
are following almost like you know if
you're a pilot before a flight you have
a checklist that you follow the same
kind of thing as being advocated in
maternity care you know it's interesting
that these safety practices that have
been instituted in California have cut
the state's maternal death rate in
what are the other states what can they
learn from what California is doing
California is a great example they are
one of the early adopters where an
organization out there has really pushed
hospitals to follow these evidence-based
best practices and they've seen the
results there is a growing movement
across the country by a group called the
aim program but but hospitals the whole
process has been slow to adopt the other
issue raises blood pressure aren't
hospitals always monitoring your blood
pressure when you're giving birth they
absolutely are but but the issue is is
that there needs to be greater
recognition that a woman's body changes
during pregnancy and after birth they
are much more susceptible to stroke when
their blood pressures reach certain
danger levels and we found I mean we
feature the case of a woman named
Yolanda mention I mean this woman had
these blood pressures above a danger
level and yet was discharged from scotts
paying attention yeah really important
thank you out some great report oh thank
you